six douilles en deçà des journalistes et
spécialistes de la guinée bonjour sidi
en scène et merci d'être avec nous ce
midi sur rt france alors on l'a dit les
bureaux de vote ont ouvert il ya
quelques heures maintenant est-ce que
vous avez déjà des retours sur la
mobilisation des guinéens pour ce début
de scrutin pour les premiers retours
c'est que la population comme se
mobilisait les oeufs
elle est quand même très motivés pour
aller exprimer son point de vue son son
opinion sur ce vote
la sauce mobilise certaines localités je
pense avait encore de chaque commune
elle encore du mal à ouvrir les les
bureaux de vote
mais ça ce sont des choses qui parfois
arrivent durant les élections en guinée
il ya des retards à l'allumage mais
généralement à partir de 9h 9h30 souvent
quelques car les choses les choses se
dérouler mais ya parfois des manques de
bureaux de vote et ça c'est une chose on
constate régulièrement de l'élection de
présidentielle c'était pareil en 2015 ou
des bureaux de vote qui sont censées se
trouver à certains endroits ne sont pas
rares et donc il faut trouver des
solutions à l'improviste et ça aussi de
céder la nature parfois à augmenter un
peu le doute de la légitimité de
l'élection
alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure un
campagne présidentielle assez compliqué
1 depuis un an en guinée qu'est-ce que
vous retiendrai de cette année à bas de
cette année c'est surtout ce qu'on a
seule chose à retenir je pense c'est que
déjà il ya cette volonté farouche de la
part du pouvoir et donc ne présente plus
faconde et à se maintenir coûte que
coûte sans vraiment expliquer pourquoi
les légitimer la logistique la
légitimité de cette volonté de la 3ème
mandat au vu des ja de l'âge et avancés
du côlon la république et on l'a vu dans
les interviews un an un monsieur qui
aujourd'hui a beaucoup de mal à
s'exprimer beaucoup de mal dans
l'élocution
on a même l'impression que ses capacités
physiques on va très bien qu elles sont
diminuées intellectuelle des choses
parfois des difficultés à ce souvenir
d'événements récents à a exprimé son
opinion
mais surtout surtout je pense que le
lâche que vraiment véritable chose dont
il faut se rappeler c'est ce fameux
référendum du lobe de mars dernier
nouvelle constitution un référendum donc
qui a été positif ou non un nouveau
texte constitutionnel sauf que le s
constitutionnel qui a été proposé
quelques l'objet de sensibilisation de
promotion au cas des populations
guinéennes et qui donc a été adopté avec
un oui massif
ce n'est pas le même texte qui a été
ensuite promulguée par le chef de l'état
il ya donc là quelque chose qui est de
nature à briser totalement le reste de
confiance qui existait en éditant un
parti politique
la qu'apporterait une victoire de cellou
dalein diallo à la guinée par rapport à
un troisième mandat d'alpha condé à bâle
à ce que ça apporterait au delà de la
personne et soudaine vial hausse après
déjà une chose historique pour
l'histoire de la guinée c'est une
alternance politique via le vote et non
pas via la mort d'un président qui s'est
maintenu au pouvoir à vie ou par l'état
militaire donc ça c'est une c'est une
c'est un quelque chose d'historique s'il
y avait une alternance par les urnes et
c'est quelque chose je pense que les
guinéens demande absolument pas
forcément la victoire de l'eusew dalein
diallo et le challenger le plus
important face à au président sortant
mais quel que soit le gagnant ou la
gagnante ce serait une alternance
démocratique dans ce pays pour une
soixante deux ans d'existence de
dépendances mais quelle a été la
réaction du peuple
guinéen quand alpha condé à a voulu pour
une troisième fois se présenter à cette
élection présidentielle
la réaction est avant tout de
l'opposition qui a su se ressouder il
faut dire qu'en fait cette annonce de
nouvelle constitution a permis de
ressouder une opposition qui était déjà
éclaté à barbe de forget se spécifie
était dédiée terroir le cassis
n'existant qu'en tout cas dans le dans
le champ politique
donc cette annonce d'un troisième mandat
regardent avant le troisième mandat mais
d'une constitution qui laissait supposer
qu'ils avaient la reprise et le mandat
de la part président alpha condé c'est
que on a une mobilisation quasi deux
inédites dans le pays qui va dans les
rues de conakry
cette vague rouge tous ces personnes
habillée en rouge et couleurs du front
national pour la défense de la
constitution qui ont inondé les rues de
conakry sont totalement inédits et c'est
surtout ça en fait ça a montré qu'il y
avait quand même une large partie de la
sanguine qui était contre une nouvelle
constitution et contre la possibilité
maintenant le vérifier la troisième
d'une fin d'une candidature pour un
troisième mandat du que dans l faconde
et c'est surtout ça en fait ça a
démontré une très grande partie était
close
voilà alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure
dans le sujet notre reporter mon âme ou
dès lors les deux candidats ont beaucoup
de deux militants de supporters est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on est en mesure de
dégager
peut-être le futur vainqueur
un favori en tout cas je pense que c'est
je voudrais plutôt s'en garder parce que
il y as je vous le rappelle un déficit
de confiance totale entre les différents
partis politiques et surtout on est
partis politiques les candidats les onze
candidats face à mme esso alpha condé
est il ce déficit de confiance
il est légitime en fait parce que le
pouvoir n'a eu de cesse de faire des
erreurs de communication des erreurs
stratégiques et avait parfois
l'impression qu'il était prêt à
s'imposer pour arriver à imposer une
nouvelle constitution est prêt à
s'imposer pour une victoire quels que
soient les reproches qu'on puisse y
faire des délégations régionales de paix
réunir en guinée avant le vote du 22
mars des débats de marque cette année le
vote référendaire
elles ont été les une fin de non
recevoir on a vraiment l'impression que
le pouvoir coûte que coûte de se
maintenir bits ce qui est intéressant
c'est que en guinée le vote c'est vrai
très ethnique mais le bilan du président
alpha condé n'est pas très glorieux en
fait et ça c'est ça avant son propre
fief de haute-guinée
les gens se rendent compte il ya eu de
nombreuses manifestations ces derniers
mois vous demandez d'accès à
l'électricité
l'accès à l'eau courante et puis surtout
l'accès au bitumage des routes dans des
fiefs important du pouvoir vous n'avez
qu'elles n'ont pas de routes de bitume
au dans les deux préfectures
donc il ya aussi un bilan qui est
extrêmement dur à défendre pour la part
du pouvoir et qui d'ailleurs ne n'en
parle pas trop parle beaucoup plus des
adversaires en disant que si on revient
de pouvoir sont d'anciens premiers
ministres se sont dans le sept personnes
qui ont donc collaboré entre guillemets
ou avec les voir pressés dont ils ont
contribué à la misère de la guinée mais
ce discours je sais pas à voir
maintenant s'il va tenir les six va être
pris en compte par les échos
merci beaucoup si beyoncé n'est d'avoir
été avec nous ce midi sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste de la guinée merci beaucoup